اضيف لما تقوله الان القناه ال 14ش
الاسرائيليه تؤكد مقتل شخص واصابه اربعه
على الاقل بجروح قطيره في حوادث الدهس
والطعن في رعنانا اذا تم تاكيد مقتل شخص
بحسب القناه ال 14ب عش الاسرائيليه واصابه
اربعه على الاقل بجروح خطيره التقييم
اختلف الان هناك
حاله وفاه لشخص الجانب الاسرائيلي نقلا عن
القناه الراعه عش الاسرائيليه يقول مقتل
شخص واصابه اربعه على اقل بجروح خطيره هذه
معلومات يفترض بعدها سيد يزبك اعود الى ان
يكون هناك وضوح في المسبب وال على الاقل
من المنفذ هناك ارقام للسيارات هناك وضوح
في الصور لماذا لا يتم الحديث الاذاعه
العبريه تقول تحييد سائق المركبه في
رعنانا بدات الصوره تتضح اعود اليك سيد
يزبك الاذاعه العبريه اذا تحييد سائق
المركبه في رعنانا الشرطه تجري عمليه بحث
عن مشتبه فيهم اخرين اذا تحييد هذا
المصطلح الذي يستخدم عاده للدلاله
على القتل اذا تحيد سائق المركبه في
رعنانا والشرطه تجري عمليات بحث عن مشتبه
فيهم اخرين اذا هل ترجح بان يكون بالفعل
من خلال هذه المعلومات انه عمل امني هل
يمكن الحديث عن عمل امني
ن ابدا استاذ العزيز لانه يعني احنا شهدنا
في الاشهر الاخيره انه كانت هنالك حواده
قتل ليهود اسرائيليين تم الاشتباه بهم
وكانهم يقوموا بعمليه امنيه وانما يعني هم
يهود عاديين ولكن لانتشار الاسلحه الان
الاسلحه منتشره في كل مكان في اسرائيل
الناس العاديين حينما تذهب الى السوبر
ماركت انت يعني يذهب الشخص مع سلاح سلاح
من النوع الطويل ليس مجرد يعني سلاح صغير
فالكل المجتمع الاسرائيلي مسلح فانا اعتقد
الان يعني واحده من الفرضيات تكون انه
شاهد هنالك مشهد شخص ما شاهد مشهد اثار
اهتمامه واستعمل سلاحه وقتل هذا السائق
الذي كان في السياره ولا يعرف من هو هذا
السائق ا معتقدا انه فلسطيني يقوم بعمليه
امنيه قد قد يظهر لنا بعد قليل ان هذا
السائق هو يهودي وتم قتله بسلاح يهودي
لانه الوضع ككل الذي تعيشه يعيشه المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وضع متوتر جدا ولذلك اي روايه
حتى الان دون ان يخرج متحدث رسمي من قبل
الشرطه ويتحدث الى الناس يطمئنهم على
الاقل ماذا يحدث وهذا هو الفشل يعني انت
الان ترى الفشل امام عينك
لانه سيد يزبك يعني بالمنطق اذا كان هناك
عمليه تحييد كما يقول او
قتل الشخص المشتبه
به هويته معروفه
يفترض الجسد موجود اليس
كذلك لا استاذ العزيز لانه في فوضه مثل ما
قلت لك هذا يذكرني بحادث حدث ح قبل حوالي
شهر ونص في القدس حينما خرج شخص ما من
سيارته واراد ان يطلق النار على فلسطيني
فاطلق فجاء الجيش واطلق النار عليه واخذ
حوالي 24 ساعه حتى استطاعوا ان يتعرفوا
على هويه ذلك القات المقتول اليهودي وهو
يحمل بطاقه هويه في جيده يعني حوالي 24
ساعه حتى تصرحوا من هو وكيف هو والمجتمع
كان يعيش في تلك الفتره يعني في فتره
حقيقه صعبه جدا من توتر والان يعني ما زال
هذا المجتمع وهذه ليس المجتمع فقط بل
المؤسسه الامنيه ان كانت الشرطه او غيرها
تعيش يعني فوضى كامله هذا هالفوضى يعني
مردها الى قبل حوالي 100 يوم ما زالت نفس
الفوضه موجوده